Bueno, ¿alguno de Uds. ha buscado esta palabra alguna vez?
¿En un diccionario? (Risas) Sí. Eso es lo que pensé.
¿Y esta palabra?
Miren, les mostraré:
Lexicografía: la práctica de compilar diccionarios.
Fíjense, somos muy específicos. La palabra "compilar"
El diccionario no se esculpe a partir de una pieza de granito,
de un pedazo de piedra. Se compone de un montón de pedacitos.
Pedacitos discretos.
Esto se deletrea así: D-I-S-C-R-E-T-O-S pedacitos.
Y esos pedacitos son palabras.
Una de las ventajas de ser lexicógrafa,
además de que me inviten a venir a TED, es que una dice palabras realmente divertidas,
como lexicográfico.
La palabra lexicográfico tiene un patrón interesante.
Se llama doble dáctilo. Y con solo decir "doble dáctilo",
he logrado que el indicador de tragalibros se haya ido completamente a la zona roja. (Risas)
Pero "lexicográfico" tiene el mismo patrón que "sin orden, ni concierto".
¿No? Es divertido pronunciar estas palabras,
y yo tengo la oportunidad de decirlas muchas veces.
Bueno, una desventaja de ser lexicógrafa
es que la gente no piensa en el diccionario como una cosa blandita, abrigada y calentita.
¿Verdad? Nadie abraza a los diccionarios.
Pero lo que la gente piensa a menudo que el diccionario es algo así.
Para que sepan, yo no tengo ningún silbato lexicográfico.
Pero la gente piensa que mi trabajo es dejar que las palabras buenas
hagan esa maniobra para entrar al diccionario,
y dejar las palabras malas afuera.
Pero en realidad es que no quiero ser guardia de tráfico.
Para empezar, no me gustan los uniformes.
Además, decidir qué palabras buenas son buenas
y cuáles malas no es algo fácil.
Ni tampoco divertido. Y cuando hay cosas del trabajo que no son ni fáciles ni divertidas,
se suelen buscar excusas para no hacerlas.
Así, si tuviera que pensar en algún oficio
como metáfora de mi trabajo, preferiría ser pescadora.
Quiero tirar mi gran red al profundo océano azul del inglés
para ver qué criaturas maravillosas puedo sacar del fondo.
Pero, ¿por qué querrían que dirigiera el tráfico, gustándome mucho más pescar?
Pues, le echo la culpa a la Reina.
¿Por qué culpo a la Reina?
Bueno, para empezar, culpo a la Reina porque es gracioso.
Pero en segundo lugar, la culpo porque
los diccionarios no han cambiado realmente.
Nuestra idea de qué es un diccionario no ha cambiado desde su reinado.
Lo único que no le agradaría a la Reina Victoria de los diccionarios modernos
es la inclusión de la palabrota más ofensiva, cosa que sucede
en los diccionarios americanos desde 1965.
Existe este tipo de la época victoriana.
James Murray, el primer editor del diccionario de inglés de Oxford.
No tengo ese sombrero. Ojalá lo tuviera.
Así que él es el responsable de mucho
de lo que consideramos moderno en los diccionarios hoy.
Cuando un tipo así, con un sombrero así,
representa la modernidad, tenemos un problema.
Por eso, James Murray podría trabajar en cualquier diccionario hoy.
No tendría que aprender nada nuevo.
Y, claro, algunos pensamos: ¡Las computadoras!
¡Computadoras! ¿Qué hay de las computadoras?
En cuanto a las computadoras -- me encantan las computadoras.
Es decir, soy una tragalibros, me encantan las computadoras.
Haría huelga de hambre antes de permitirles que me quiten la búsqueda de Google Libros.
Pero las computadoras no hacen mucho más que
acelerar el proceso de compilar diccionarios.
No cambian el resultado final.
Porque un diccionario es,
es su diseño victoriano unido con un poco de propulsión moderna.
Es fuerza de vapor. Lo que tenemos es un velocípedo eléctrico.
Ya saben, tenemos un diseño victoriano con motor, ¡nada más!
El diseño no ha cambiado.
OK, ¿qué hay de los diccionarios en línea?
Los diccionarios en Internet deben ser diferentes.
Este es el Diccionario Inglés de Oxford en línea, uno de los mejores diccionarios en línea.
Esta es mi palabra favorita, de hecho:
"Erinaceous": que tiene que ver con el erizo u otro animal parecido; parecido al erizo.
Es una palabra muy útil. Fíjense.
Los diccionarios electrónicos actuales son más hojas de papel en pantalla.
Esto es plano. Miren cuántos enlaces hay en la entrada: ¡dos!
¿Verdad? Esos botoncitos,
los tenía todos expandidos, menos la tabla de fechas.
Así que no pasa nada por aquí.
No hay mucho en qué hacer clic.
De hecho, los diccionarios electrónicos duplican
casi todos los inconvenientes del impreso, exceptuando el poder de hacer búsquedas.
Y cuando mejora la capacidad de búsqueda,
se pierde la única ventaja de lo impreso, que es la serendipia.
La serendipia es cuando encuentras algo que no buscabas
porque encontrar lo que buscas es terriblemente difícil.
Así es, (Risas) al examinar el asunto,
lo que tenemos es el problema de la cola del jamón.
¿Alguien conoce el problema de la cola del jamón?
Una mujer prepara jamón para una cena familiar.
Empieza a quitar la cola del jamón para tirarla,
y mira ese trozo de jamón, y se pregunta,
"Es un trozo en muy buen estado. ¿Por qué lo tiro?"
Y piensa, "Bueno, mi mamá siempre lo hacía."
Entonces llama a su mamá, y le dice,
"Mamá, ¿por qué siempre quitabas la cola del jamón cuando lo preparabas?"
Ella responde, "No lo sé, mi mamá siempre lo hacía así."
Entonces llaman a la abuela, y la abuela les dice,
"¡El jamón no cabía en la cacerola!" (Risas)
Entonces no es que tengamos buenas y malas palabras
¡tenemos una cacerola demasiado pequeña!
Ya saben, ¡esa cola del jamón es muy rica! No se debe tirar.
Las malas palabras, —cuando la gente piensa en un lugar
y no lo encuentra en el mapa,
suele pensar, "Este mapa es malo!"
Pero cuando conoce un club o un bar que no se encuentra en la guía,
piensan, "qué bien, este lugar debe ser bueno! No figura en la guía."
Cuando encuentran alguna palabra que no está en el diccionario, piensan,
"Debe ser una mala palabra." ¿Por qué? Es más probable que sea un mal diccionario.
¿Por qué culpamos el jamón por ser demasiado grande para la cacerola?
No se puede conseguir un jamón más pequeño.
El idioma inglés es tan grande como es.
Entonces si se tiene un problema como el de la cola del jamón,
y pensamos en el problema de la cola del jamón,
la conclusión a la que nos dirige es inevitable y contraintuitiva:
El papel es el enemigo de las palabras.
¿Cómo puede ser? Quiero decir, me encantan los libros. De verdad me encantan los libros.
Algunos de mis mejores amigos son libros.
Pero el libro no es el mejor formato para el diccionario.
Ahora van a pensar, "Dios mío.
Me van a quitar mis queridos diccionarios en papel?"
No. Seguirán siendo diccionarios en papel.
Al tener autos, cuando pasaron a ser el principal medio de transporte,
no juntamos todos los caballos para fusilarlos.
Saben, todavía habrá diccionarios en papel,
pero no será el diccionario predominante.
El diccionario en forma de libro no será la única forma
en la que existirán los diccionarios. Y no será
El prototipo para los próximos diccionarios.
Piénsenlo así: si se tiene una restricción artificial,
estas restricciones artificiales nos conducen a
distinciones arbitrarias y una cosmovisión torcida.
¿Qué pasaría si los biólogos sólo pudieran estudiar los animales
que le hicieran a la gente decir, "Guau." ¿No?
¿Qué pasaría si juzgáramos estéticamente a los animales,
y sólo estudiásemos los que nos parecen bonitos?
Sabríamos mucho sobre la megafauna carismática,
y no mucho sobre muchas otras cosas.
Y pienso que eso es un problema.
Pienso que deberíamos estudiar todas las palabras,
porque al pensar en palabras, se puede formar expresiones bellas
partiendo de partes muy humildes.
La lexicografía es en realidad más sobre las ciencia de los materiales.
Estudiamos la tolerancia de los materiales
que usamos para construir la estructura de su expresión:
lo que dicen y lo que escriben. Y muchas veces me dicen,
"¿Cómo sabré si esta palabra es verdadera?"
Piensan, "Bueno, si pensamos que las palabras son las herramientas
que usamos para construir las expresiones de los pensamientos,
¿cómo se puede decir que los destornilladores son mejores que los martillos?
¿Cómo se puede decir que la almádena es mejor que el martillo de bola?
Son justo las herramientas perfectas para su trabajo."
Entonces me dicen, "¿Cómo se sabe si una palabra es real?"
Bien, todos los que hayan leído un libro para niños
saben que el amor hace las cosas reales.
Si te gusta una palabra, úsala. El uso la hace real.
Estar en el diccionario es una distinción artificial.
No hace que una palabra sea más real que cualquier otra manera.
Si te gusta una palabra, se hace real.
Así es que si no nos preocupamos por dirigir el tráfico,
si hemos transcendido el papel, si nos preocupamos menos
por el control y más por la descripción,
entonces podemos pensar más en el idioma inglés
como un bello móvil.
Y siempre que una partecita del móvil cambie,
se toque, siempre que se toque una palabra,
se use en algún contexto nuevo, le damos una nueva connotación,
se verbaliza, hacemos que el móvil se mueva.
No la rompimos; sólo está en una nueva posición,
y esa nueva posición puede ser igual de bella.
Si ya no eres guardia de tráfico,
el problema con ser guardia de tráfico es
que en cualquier cruce puede haber muchos policías,
o se confunden los autos, ¿verdad?
Pero si la meta ya no es dirigir el tráfico,
sino tal vez contar los autos que pasan, entonces cuántos más ojos mejor.
¡Se puede pedir ayuda!
Si se pide ayuda, se logra hacer más. Y realmente necesitamos ayuda.
La Biblioteca del Congreso: 17 millones de libros,
de los cuales la mitad están en inglés.
Si solamente uno de cada diez de esos libros
tuviera una palabra que no está en el diccionario,
eso equivaldría a más de dos diccionarios íntegros.
Y yo encuentro una palabra no adiccionariada,
una palabra como "adiccionariada", por ejemplo,
en casi todos los libros que leo. ¿Y qué tal los periódicos?
El archivo de los periódicos se remonta a 1759.
58.1 millones de páginas de periódicos. Si sólo una en 100
de esas páginas tuviera una palabra no adiccionariada,
sería como otro Diccionario Inglés de Oxford completo.
Son 500.000 palabras más. Eso es mucho.
Y ni hablar de las revistas, ni de los blogs.
Encuentro más nuevas palabras en BoingBoing en una semana
que en las revistas Newsweek o Time.
Allí suceden muchas cosas.
Y ni hablar de polisemia,
que es la costumbre codiciosa de algunas palabras de agenciarse
más de una definición.
Así si piensan en la palabra "set", un "set" puede ser la madriguera de un tejón,
un "set" puede ser uno de los pliegues en una gorguera isabelina,
y hay una definición numerada en el DIO (Diccionario Inglés de Oxford)
El DIO tiene 33 definiciones distintas para "set".
Una palabra pequeñita, 33 definiciones numeradas.
Una de ellas se titula simplemente "sentidos técnicos misceláneos".
¿Saben qué me indica eso?
Me indica que era un viernes por la tarde y alguien quería irse al bar.
Es una irresponsabilidad lexicográfica
decir "sentidos técnicos misceláneos".
Así es que tenemos todas estas palabras, ¡y realmente necesitamos ayuda!
Y la cosa es que, podríamos pedir ayuda,
pedir ayuda no es tan difícil.
Quiero decir, la lexicografía no es ciencia espacial.
Vean, acabo de darles una cantidad de palabras y de números,
y ésta es más una explicación visual.
Si pensamos en el diccionario como si fuera un mapa del idioma inglés,
estos puntos claros representan lo que sabemos
y las áreas oscuras son lo que ignoramos.
Si ese es el mapa de todas las palabras del inglés estadounidense, no sabemos mucho.
Ni sabemos los contornos del idioma.
Si esto fuera el diccionario, si fuera el mapa del inglés estadounidense,
miren, tenemos una idea algo vaga de la Florida,
pero ¡no existe California!
Nos hace falta California en el inglés estadounidense.
Es que no sabemos lo suficiente, ni siquiera sabemos que nos hace falta California.
Ni siquiera vemos que hay un hueco en el mapa.
Así que, nuevamente, en la lexicografía no hace falta ser científico espaciale.
Pero aún si lo fuera, las investigaciones espaciales las harían
aficionados dedicados hoy en día, ¿no?
¡No puede ser tan difícil encontrar unas cuantas palabras!
Entonces, un montón de científicos en otras disciplinas
les piden a la gente que ayuden, y les va bien.
Por ejemplo, en el eBird, donde observadores de aves aficionados
pueden subir información sobre las aves que han visto.
Y luego los ornitólogos pueden ir
y ayudar a seguir las poblaciones, migraciones, etcétera.
Y está este tipo, Mike Oates. Mike Oates vive en el Reino Unido.
Es director de una empresa de galvanoplastia.
Ha encontrado más de 140 cometas.
Ha encontrado tantos cometas que pusieron su nombre a uno.
Está por ahí, pasando Marte, un poco lejos de aquí.
No creo que pueda conseguir sacarse una foto allí pronto.
Pero encontró 140 cometas sin telescopio.
Descargó datos del satélite SOHO de la NASA,
y así es como los encontró.
Si podemos encontrar cometas sin telescopio,
¿no podremos encontrar palabras?
Ahora, Uds. ya saben por dónde voy con todo esto.
Porque voy a Internet, que es a donde todo el mundo va.
E Internet es maravilloso para juntar palabras,
porque Internet está lleno de coleccionistas.
Y esto es un hecho tecnológico poco conocido de Internet,
pero Internet realmente está hecho con palabras y entusiasmo.
Y las palabras y el entusiasmo, de hecho, son
la receta para la lexicografía. ¿No es genial?
Hay muchos sitios muy buenos para juntar palabras hoy en día,
pero el problema con algunos de ellos es que no son lo suficientemente científicos.
Muestran una palabra, pero no muestran ningún contexto:
¿De dónde vino? ¿Quién la dijo?
¿En qué periódico apareció? ¿En qué libro?
Porque una palabra es como una pieza arqueológica.
Si no sabes la procedencia de la pieza,
no es ciencia, es algo bonito para mirar.
Entonces, una palabra sin raíces es como una flor cortada.
Es bonita para admirarla por un rato, pero luego se muere.
Se muere demasiado rápido.
Bueno, todo este tiempo estuve diciendo,
"El diccionario, el diccionario, el diccionario, el diccionario."
No "un diccionario," o "diccionarios." Y eso es porque…
Bueno, la gente usa el diccionario para representar al idioma entero.
Lo usa sinécdoquicamente,
y uno de los problemas de conocer una palabra como "sinécdoquicamente"
es que quieres cualquier excusa para usar "sinécdoquicamente".
Esta charla ha sido pues tan solo una excusa para
poder "sinécdoquicamente" a todos Uds.
Lo siento mucho. Pero cuando usas una parte de algo,
como el diccionario, que es parte de la lengua,
o una bandera que representa EE.UU., un símbolo del país,
entonces lo usas sinécdoquicamente.
Pero es que, podríamos hacer del diccionario el idioma entero.
Si conseguimos una cacerola más grande, entonces cabrán todas las palabras.
Podemos poner todos los significados.
¿Y no queremos todos más significado en nuestras vidas?
Y podemos hacer que el diccionario no sea sólo un símbolo del idioma;
podemos hacer que sea el idioma mismo.
Vean, lo que realmente espero es que mi hijo
quien cumple siete años este mes, que apenas recuerde
que ésta es la forma que tenían los diccionarios.
Que esta es la apariencia que tenían los diccionarios.
Quiero que él piense en este tipo de diccionario como en una cinta de ocho pistas.
Es un formato que desaparició por no ser suficientemente útil.
No era lo que la gente necesitaba realmente.
Y la cosa es, si podemos incluir todas las palabras,
si podemos olvidar esa distinción artificial entre lo bueno y lo malo,
podemos describir el idioma como científicos.
Podemos dejar los juicios estéticos a los escritores y a los oradores.
Si logramos hacer eso, entonces puedo pasar mi tiempo pescando.
y ya no tendré que ser más guardia de tráfico.
Muchísimas gracias por su amable atención.